the nhl is ready to put 2020 behind and
move on
to the 2021 season this afternoon the
league announced
its plans to begin the new season next
month pretty much everything we've been
reporting will happen
they made it official today that'd be
nice to see practice crank up again at
city national arena
that will happen two weeks from today
some of the players told us they've been
working out on their own getting ready
for the season good thing
it's all going to happen very quickly
from here on out so here are the
highlights from today's news
training camp january 3rd first games on
the 16th
they are changing things up with the
divisions it's hard to get back and
forth across the border
in the north so the seven canadian teams
will be in one division the knights will
be in a western division
eight teams there you know all the west
teams and put minnesota in there
as well so that would fill out the
division for the knights there's going
to be a shortened season
56 games regular season games with the
playoffs beginning in early may
no preseason the nhl is hoping teams
will be able to play in their home
arenas
and no reason to think that the knights
won't be able to play here at t-mobile
arena
as for fans the nhl says it's up to
local rules on that so let's see
fans at the knights games in 2021 would
be